bonjour et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur rtl france
situation alarmante pour les
sages-femmes concrètement comment se
passe aujourd'hui voilà cette prise en
charge dans les hôpitaux et pourquoi
vous redoutez justement un été
dramatique
bonjour alors comment se passer la prise
en charge elle essayait de se passer là
plus normalement possible c'est à dire
que les femmes font mieux avec des
effectifs qu'elles ont pour prendre en
charge les femmes alors dans des
conditions qui sont dégradées dans le
sens où de plus en plus de sa chambre
prennent en charge de plus en plus de
femmes en même temps d'autant plus avec
une des effectifs qui sont réduits au
minimum
donc on fait on fait comme on peut mais
ça devient très compliqué tout
simplement parce que il ya 25 ans nous
avions 1500 maternité est à peu près
1000 sages femmes libérales
ce qui faisait à peu près de 2500 lieu
de travail potentiel pour des
remplacements
aujourd'hui nous avons 500 maternité et
7000 sages femmes libérales donc 7500
lieux potentiels de travail pour l'été
pour les remplacements
c'est mathématique on ne peut pas on
veut pas assurée tous les remplacements
il ya une année aussi qu vide assez
compliqué pour les étudiantes qui font
que pâtissier qu' il ya eu un certain
nombre de jeunes filles qui n'ont pas
été diplômé le jeune garçon aussi donc
on autant en libéral que dans les
maternités que dans les services de
protection maternelle et infantile
c'est très compliqué on manque
énormément de personnel des contrats
précaires des salaires jugé beaucoup
trop bas
comment se sont déroulées les
discussions avec le ministère de la
santé dans le cadre du ségur de la santé
est ce qu'il y avait des promesses qui
n'ont pas été tenues
alors nous par rapport aux ségur nous
n'y avons pas été associés tout
simplement dans le sens où les
sages-femmes nous sommes une profession
médicale mais à l'hôpital notre statut
de nous permet pas de rentrer dans les
négociations par exemple nous en tant
que syndicat professionnel puisque les
sages femmes sont fonctionnaires sous
son nom les les centrales syndicales qui
négocient pour nous or les centrales
syndicales sont en majorité par
représentant majorité les personnels qui
sont très nombreux les infirmiers les
aides soignants dont nous n'avons pas
vraiment voix au chapitre ce qui fait
que nous avons une revalorisation qui
correspond à des personnels qui sont non
médicaux donc qui pourrait le prendre
absolument pas notre niveau de
responsabilité notre niveau d'études
il avait été promis par le gouvernement
que nous ayons une qui est des réunions
concernant nos rémunérations au premier
semestre 2021 alors pendant ce premier
semestre
il y a eu rapport de l'igas de
l'inspection générale des affaires
sociales qui a été menée nous avons été
entendus plusieurs fois et les
différentes organisations qui
représentent les sages femmes l'ont été
aussi
nous attendons toujours ce rapport qui
était censé sortir début juin puis fin
juin ou début juillet nous sommes le 10
juillet nous n'avons toujours rien donc
nous commençons à nous impatienter
grandement justement on sait que il est
plusieurs manifestations de sages-femmes
cette année est ce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
le dernier recours encore une fois pour
se faire entendre pour faire entendre
votre votre colère wynn ho là là nous
nous avons essayé c'est ces méthodes là
qui portent pas énormément leurs fruits
on le voit bien donc nous en tant que
syndicat nous nous faisons du coup de
pouce apparenté à du lobbying nous
communiquons avec le ministère avec nos
interlocuteurs institutionnels mais mais
visiblement c'est c on est toujours pas
entendu donc on par la force des choses
là le contexte actuel va je l'espère
faire réaliser aux gouvernements que
nous sommes d'une profession à laquelle
il va falloir ça m'intéressait parce que
c'est c'est avec nous que fonctionne le
système périnatale français et beaucoup
ça repose beaucoup sur nos écrans quand
même même si nous travaillons évidemment
avec d'autres protagonistes les médecins
les aides soignantes ou les infirmières
les auxiliaires de puériculture alors
vous attendez que la situation évolue
dans le cas contraire quels pourraient
être les répercussions sur justement les
patients qui viennent vous voir les
patients qui vont à l'hôpital pour
accoucher patiente alors pour les
patientes qui a qui arrivent à l'hôpital
ça veut dire moins de sages-femmes pour
plus de patientes donc ça veut dire une
prise en charge qui sera forcément moins
humaine
en tout cas aussi humaine que ce qu'on
puisse le faire mais si on doit se
diviser en 3 ans 4 en salle de naissance
à un moment donné c'est humainement
impossible que d'assurer comme on l'aimé
notre commission et nous espérons tous
du bois pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
situations dramatiques pendant l'été
avec des voyages et des choses qu'on
peut redouter sur des femmes qui serait
obligée d'accoucher seule dans une
chambre parce qu'il n'ya pas le
personnel pour venir les aider et être
avec elle donc nous chaque jour chaque
chose chaque sage femme qui prend sa
garde espère que tout va bien se passer
et ça met en danger tout le monde s'est
mis en danger les sages femmes les
femmes les bébés et puis tous les
personnels qui travaillent avec nous
parce que on redoute toujours une
urgence qu'on n'aura pas le temps de
prendre en charge une urgence con con
percevra trop tard donc c'est vraiment
on marche sur des oeufs
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de sages
femmes qui vont qui prennent leur garde
avec une certaine appréhension de bon
j'espère qu'aujourd'hui à tout va bien
se passer tout va rouler parce que s'il
ya quelque chose qui ne va pas est-ce
que je vais être là pour pouvoir le
problème ça merci beaucoup en tout cas
charlotte baut des béatitudes d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin je
rappelle que vous êtes la secrétaire
adjointe de l'organisation syndicale des
sages femmes